[Applause]
[Music]
today there are about 25 countries
without an army but i'll ask you which
one of them was first which country do
you think was the first to voluntarily
give up
its armed forces if you guessed a
european country you're not even on the
right continent it was actually
a latin american country and that was of
course costa rica
[Music]
on december the first 1948 after a civil
war under president jose ferguerrez
farah's administration costa rica put an
end
to its military career and you know what
this wasn't actually a bad
move
[Music]
since then the country hasn't had a
single war or a
single coup in fact costa rica can boast
about being the country with the longest
uninterrupted period of democratic
government
in latin america because de viewer let's
not forget the enormous way that the
military boot has traditionally had on
latin america
then there's the fact that costa rica is
located in one of the most violent
regions
in the world central america
well despite this this tropical country
located between the caribbean sea and
the pacific ocean has
managed to become a middle-income
country with quite high levels of
prosperity so what's the recipe here
well prosperity peace
and safety these are the ingredients
that have made costa rica habitually
known
as the switzerland of latin america now
what is true in all of this and in this
video we want to tell you a bit more
about costa rica we want to
have a look at its light but also at its
shadows so let's dive in
[Music]
the happy face
however we look at it costa rica is a
very special country
we're talking about a country whose
hallmark color is green because if costa
rica is associated with anything
it's biodiversity
you see with an area that's almost 10
times smaller than that of spain or 25
times smaller than peru this country is
estimated to have more than
5 percent of all the world's animal and
plant biodiversity and
in this country they understand this is
not just a sign of identity but also a
potentially
great competitive advantage
[Music]
for example among other things it can
help develop a differentiated tourism
industry and
position a strong country brand that is
to say one that gives higher value to
local products especially for
international consumers
[Music]
because who wouldn't be willing to pay a
bit more for products considered to be
produced cleanly and in an environmental
haven and costa ricans while they take
these policies very
very seriously costa rica strives to be
an ecological power it absolutely is
today more than 25 percent of national
territory is protected and the vast
majority of electricity comes from
renewable sources hydroelectric
geothermal and wind power and not only
that costa rica
is the only country in the region and
one of the few in the world that has
managed
to reverse deforestation the territory
covered by forests has increased from
21 in 1987 to over 50 percent
in the present day
[Music]
something that by the way they achieved
thanks to a curious payment system for
environmental services allow me to
explain this
in costa rica a part of the taxes on
fuels goes to
fund costa rican forest financing a fund
that pays farm and forest owners who
want to join the program voluntarily to
conserve their natural space and
implement projects that help strengthen
it
and that's not all many companies also
pay into this fund to offset their
impact on the environment something
like corporate social responsibility
that's promoted by the state
now i think this leads to a really
interesting debate because for some
this policy is a bit of a monstrosity
whereas for others it'll be a way of
recognizing the negative externalities
of productive activities such as the
pollution
caused by factories and also of course
there's the positive externalities
on natural areas half of our territory
is covered by forests and we have an
ample system of protected areas that not
only protect an important part of the
planet's biodiversity but also sustain
important sectors of our economy as for
example tourism
carlos alvarado president of costa rica
personally i believe that if these types
of initiatives are accompanied by
policies that promote the creation of
companies and new types of businesses
they could be
really successful but let's leave it
open to debate you can let us know what
you think of all of this
in the comments but now let's move on
from this
[Music]
the fact is that this type of political
approach doesn't seem to have been
at odds with the country's economic
growth since the year 2000 the costa
rican economy has grown by around
four percent every year which even if it
doesn't seem like much has been a higher
average growth rate than that of the
rest of latin america and
the oecd countries
and that's not all costa rica is
undergoing something similar to what we
saw with new zealand if we measure
variables besides gdp
for example if we consider life
expectancy salaries the situation of
companies etc etc then costa rica
comes out even better
[Music]
we can take a look at the legatum
prosperity index and the ranking of
countries by
gdp per capita in purchasing power
parity that is taking price differences
into account
if we do we'll notice that costa rica's
gdp per capita is the sixth largest in
latin america
that is it's below chile panama uruguay
argentina and mexico and 76th in the
world in the global prosperity index
costa rica rises to the 29th place being
the second country in latin america
closely behind uruguay
but if you want some clear proof the
average life expectancy in costa rica is
the third
highest in the entire american continent
being higher for
example than that of the united states
[Music]
so costa rica it looks like a prosperous
peaceful country committed to the
preservation
of the environment which all sounds
pretty great right well
hold on for a moment because this
country has another face
costa rica is facing very complicated
challenges
so listen up
challenges that threatened the country
costa rica is a country that has
achieved great things especially if we
compare it with many of its neighbors
however right now it's facing
political economic and social challenges
that threaten its path to prosperity the
first one
clearly has got a lot to do with the
economy see even though costa rica has
had a solid performance it still
has a long way to go currently its gdp
per capita is just over 40 percent of
the average for the oecd countries
and here's the problem the last
government was how do you want to say it
a bit
irresponsible with their fiscal policy
which left costa rica in a
rather delicate situation only in the
last 10 years the public debt has more
than doubled in terms of gdp the 2018
deficit will approach
seven percent and one of every three
dollars of public spending will go
towards paying that debt while in 2008
taxes financed
70 of all central government
expenditures in 2017
they were only enough to finance 50
percent and the difference had to be
covered with indebtedness
jorge corrales quesada fortunately there
seems to be
a political consensus if this situation
doesn't change
costa rica could face several problems
but only focusing on raising taxes could
also be counterproductive the country's
tax on corporate profits is already one
of the highest
in the world and it's not only taxes for
example the cost of electricity and fuel
which lies in the hands of public
monopolies are among some of the most
expensive in the region which obviously
affects competitiveness
due to increases like these the labor
participation rate the rate of people
who work
is really rather low the president's
carlos alvarado really needs to open up
the economy and allow competition and if
possible set
a path so that the large public
companies can be shared by costa ricans
the second challenge has to do with
violence in recent years violence has
grown a lot in a country that was
traditionally very safe and very
quiet and well this does have a simple
explanation
drug traffickers yep as you may already
know drug traffickers are
ravaging a large part of latin america
and now they're trying to extend their
influence to costa rica which is a good
path
for their merchandise and
third well the third challenge has a lot
to do with politics the last elections
were a good example of how radical and
populist messages that target civil
liberties are a great threat
see the first electoral round held in
february wasn't won by carlos alvarado
but
by fabricio alvarado an evangelist
pastor who has
a very radical discourse among his
obsessions was pursuing any societal
model that differed from what he
perceived as convenient especially
anything related to equal marriage and
of course anyone can say what they want
and lead their lives however they please
but when a politician wants the
government to devote itself to religion
and persecute those who don't agree with
their life model it can become
really dangerous here is laura musca
fabrizio alvarado's wife in the middle
of their campaign
and don't try and tell me that she's not
scary
[Music]
fortunately in the second round this
evangelical pastor whose speech had
a lot of hatred and very little love
suffered a crushing defeat even though
he still won
30 of the votes but it's this sort of
populism that costa rica is going to
have to be very careful with in the
future but if you uh that's kind of the
way things are
[Music]
carlos alvarado has just been elected
president and it's now
in his hands to get costa rica back on
track to achieve this he'll have to
change a lot of things and don't forget
that the best way to fight poverty
is by promoting more dynamic open and
competitive economies
companies are no question going to have
to play a prominent role
in all of this
[Music]
but now it's your turn do you think that
costa rica's green model is one
other countries should follow do you
think that costa rica itself
is a model to follow well leave your
answers in the comments as well as in
this survey and i really hope you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button if you did and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for brand
new videos every monday and every
thursday also don't forget to check out
our friends at the reconsider media
podcast they provided the
vocals in this episode that were not
mine and as always
thank you for watching